Being yet another devastating exposure of
the line of Donald Trump.
Former national security advisor, John Bolton
is now confirming the entire Trump Ukraine
extortion military aid, Biden smear story
in his book, and Trump is now even more panicked
about preventing John Bolton from testifying
publicly.
I already told you last week they were panicking.
They are very much now panicking.
We really need to understand the scope and
the seriousness of this story because it is
almost beyond belief.
We are operating in a universe where if you
said to someone living five years ago and
following politics, this is what will be going
on in 2020.
Uh, no one would believe it as a screenplay.
It would be too farfetched.
The latest is that John Bolton says in the
manuscript for his upcoming book as yet unpublished,
that Donald Trump straight up told him personally.
Remember, Republicans say they want firsthand
witnesses.
They don't want hearsay or hearsay.
As we've heard.
Some of them say Bolton was told by Trump
withhold the military aid to Ukraine until
they publicly smear Joe Biden.
I specifically said last week, what John Bolton
needs to do is go public with what's in the
book.
Check out what I said when I looked, uh, when
last week it looked like Republicans were
going to try to obstruct a Bolton from testifying
or make him testify behind closed doors.
This is what I said last week.
I hope that John Bolton just goes public.
Bolton has a book that will be published sometime
this year before the election.
Even if it's just to sell books, I want Bolton
to go public with what he knows.
If he's worried that he might sell more books
by keeping the bombshell revelations only
in the book, I think he'll sell away more
books by becoming the guy who goes public
rather than the guy teasing bombshells.
You've got to buy the book to see.
People will reward him for going public by
going out and buying the book.
Even if they never read it.
I hope we see him do it.
He's not a good guy, but he may be useful
to us in this particular case if he is to
simply go public with what he knows and what
he saw.
That was last week and Bolton is doing exactly
this if you believe that he was to some degree
involved in orchestrating the leak of this.
Of course, a Bolton's lawyer says, we gave
the manuscript to the white house and then
it leaked.
We of course have no way of knowing whether
that was part of the plan or whether it was
someone acting at the white house unilaterally
to leak this we don't know, but going public
over the weekend with the bombshell revelations
at every opportunity, Donald Trump and the
people around him have come up with every
even remotely possible hypothetical defense
for the crucial claim.
And the crucial claim of course is Trump knew
what he was doing.
He deliberately withheld aid to push Ukraine
to smear Biden publicly by announcing investigations
into him.
They've said this was really Donald Trump
trying to clean up the corruption in Ukraine.
That was Trump's concern.
Ukraine corruption.
Trump wasn't aware of the timing of the aid.
The aid was ultimately released.
And so it couldn't have been a requirement
to smear Biden since Ukraine never ended up
smearing Biden.
And they eventually got the aid.
Well, that falls apart given what we know
about when they knew they were now suspected
of doing exactly this, they had no choice
ultimately, but to release that aid and on
and on and on.
And of course, we can look at each of those
claims individually, and we have, and we've
refuted every one of them, but this is John
Bolton coming in with a storyline that start
to finish refutes all of it, right?
We've been focused on, you know, when Trump
says the aid was ultimately released, that
doesn't really exculpate them because of this.
And because of that, Bolton just comes in
and says, now I was told, withhold the aid
until they announced that they're smearing
Biden.
So understand the insanity of the upcoming
situation that we find ourselves in and a
normal situation without an impeachment trial
going on.
If a former national security advisor made
these claims, it would immediately trigger
in a pre-Trump era hearings where John Bolton
would testify under oath about this.
Okay, and alone, this might cause a president
to be impeached.
We just so happen to have a Senate impeachment
trial going on right now where there is already
a discussion of having John Bolton testify.
Republicans plan to argue likely Tuesday or
Wednesday.
Trump's lawyers are in the middle of their
24 hours to present their defense of Trump
in the Senate impeachment trial.
After that's done, senators will argue and
debate which witnesses will testify who gets
a subpoena, which ones will happen behind
closed doors or in public.
They are going to try to number one, keep
John Bolton out of this altogether, which
given what John Bolton is alleging would be
absolutely ludicrous.
If they can't keep Bolton out altogether,
they will either try to push it behind closed
doors or try to trade Bolton testifying for
pulling in Joe Biden, maybe even Hunter Biden.
They're looking at whether they want to have
the Biden's involved, which of course they
should not be.
And the dishonesty from the Trump white house
is exposed here as well.
Again, how did this leak?
Well, Bolton's lawyer says we sent a draft
of the book to the white house for review
back in December.
Somehow it was leaked since then.
That may be true.
It may have been a coordinated leak, doesn't
matter.
But what we know is the white house had a
copy of the manuscript since December, and
yet throughout January they continued to lie
about what John Bolton knew and whether John
Bolton did or didn't need to testify.
And they continued to tell a story that they
knew John Bolton debunked in his upcoming
book that Trump did nothing wrong, that there
was nothing connected between the aide and
Ukraine smears of Joe Biden.
There are all sorts of other outrageous allegations
in the book as well, which aren't making headlines
and we'll get to.
So, for example, one is according to Bolton,
Rudy Giuliani admitted that he wanted ambassador
Maria Bonovitch removed, um, because he believed
Bolton believes that Giuliani realized [inaudible]
was obstructing Giuliani's cronies from doing
corrupt things in Ukraine.
Consider the backwards, the projection there,
right?
The whole idea was Trump and Giuliani.
They wanted Ivana bitch out because she wasn't
doing enough to fight corruption in Ukraine.
It actually appears according to what John
Bolton alleges in his book, that Rudy Giuliani
wanted Ivana bitch out because she was interfering
in the corrupt acts of friends and henchmen
of Rudy Giuliani.
I mean, just, just imagine the backwards nature
of what is going on here.
People working for Rudy or with Rudy were
the corrupt ones.
Immediate questions.
Will Bolton testify?
Will Bolton testify in public?
Will?
We know about that in the next couple of days?
And the question coming on the tail end of
this of course, is, is this going to affect
whether Donald Trump gets convicted in the
Senate?
I still say probably not.
I believe that Republican senators will not
care.
We will be lucky to get four Republican senators
to vote to force Bolton to testify, but I
still don't see any path to a conviction for
Donald Trump in the Senate.
If you disagree, I want to hear from you.
Let me know.
I said this last week, nobody got in touch
saying they see a path to conviction for Donald
Trump.
If you see one get in touch